dans cette usine où l'on fabrique des
hélices de bateau
on veut aider le québec à traverser la
tempête
l'entreprise a commandé plus de cent
mille masques chirurgicaux et deux mille
masques n 95 chez un de ses fournisseurs
chinois rouler le vendre sans profit au
réseau de la santé mais on se demande si
la cargaison se rendra à bon port c'est
très difficile d'avoir une garantie que
les masques par du manufacturier pour
s'en aller directement la rue repas 5
soit interceptée par des personnes des
gens américain pour racheter les
cargaisons et les faire envoyer
directement aux états unis il y en a
même qui se postent devant les
compagnies pharmaceutiques qui fabrique
des masques labour
c'est du moins ce que lui a raconté son
fournisseur ce genre d'histoire se
multiplient depuis quelques jours les
états unis auraient détourné des masques
destinés à la france en les achetant en
argent comptant trois fois plus cher
directement sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
des livraisons à destination du canada
aurait subi le même sort
c'est vrai que sajoo 2 dans certains
pays on les nomme repos mais on joue
nous si les règles du jeu ça veut dire
des fois faut arriver avec de l'argent
comptant faut avoir des policiers des
gens qui suivent tout le transport
on va continuer de travailler avec les
etats-unis pour s'assurer à cornol
équipements dont on a besoin pour être
certain d'obtenir sa cargaison
dominique loof qu'on ne lisais un camion
en chine qu'on ait un camion qui est
directement à l'entreprise qui va partir
de la manufacture et s'en aller sans
arrêter de la manufacture jusqu'aux
avion à l'aéroport
l'autre défi pour les entrepreneurs qui
importe du matériel médical et de
prendre contact avec le réseau de la
santé maurice gendron tente depuis
plusieurs jours de frire ses services au
gouvernement du québec
sans trop de succès il est en mesure
d'obtenir des milliers de masques
chirurgicaux et n 95 pendant que ici on
dit qu'on a une pénurie de on a un
inventaire de séjour puis après ça ça
vous est écoulé pont panique
ben qui commande chez nous entre-temps
l'ontario et la saskatchewan sont en
voie de conclure d
entente avec lui ici olivier bâche un
réseau au canada montréal